consideremos el mercado para cierto tipo
de arbusto o árbol que las personas
pueden plantar en sus jardines aquí está
la cantidad de esos árboles plantados
un millón dos millones
3 millones esas son cantidades bastante
grandes al menos para un árbol en
particular 4 millones y así continúa así
que esta es la cantidad por año de
árboles plantados cantidad plantados por
año y aquí arriba voy a poner el costo
en dólares por árbol cantidad de dólares
por árbol quizás aquí son 10 dólares 20
dólares 30 dólares 40 dólares y la curva
de nuestro costo marginal o de nuestra
oferta va a lucir así para tener nuestro
primer árbol plantado que una persona lo
plante en su jardín y todo esto lo haga
en su jardín quizás nosotros tengamos
que pagarle unos 10 dólares y para cada
árbol incrementar este costo va a
aumentar por lo que nuestra curva del
costo marginal puede lucir así esta es
nuestra curva del costo marginal o de la
oferta y nuestra curva de demanda para
los primeros árboles vamos a tener un
beneficio muy alto y para cada árbol
incremental ese beneficio va a disminuir
cada vez más por lo que la curva va a
lucir así esa nuestra curva de demanda
está
es la demanda y recordemos que este es
el mercado para un árbol muy bueno muy
bonito para un buen árbol y si dejamos
que el mercado ocurra de forma natural
llegamos a una cantidad de equilibrio
bastante natural que es aproximadamente
2.7 millones de árboles plantados por
año y nuestra presión de equilibrio está
más o menos en 20 dólares por árbol y
con ello generamos toda esta área de
superávit que está repartida
esencialmente entre los consumidores de
las personas que compran estos árboles y
las personas que están produciendo o que
están promoviendo la venta de estos
árboles ahora digamos que se publica un
artículo de investigación que dice que
este tipo particular de árbol tiene
muchísimos beneficios agregados digamos
que de cierta manera está relacionado
con el control de plagas un control de
plagas natural no sé a lo mejor las
plagas kong en la madera de este árbol y
desaparecen o ahuyenta a los mosquitos
digamos que también mejora la calidad
del aire mejora la calidad del aire y
digamos que además de todo eso
es algo muy hermoso de observar incluso
si no sea su árbol cuando ustedes pasan
cerca de estos árboles los tranquilizan
los relaja les hace pensar que este
mundo no está tan mal así que son
bonitos de observar
y este artículo de investigación
determina que el beneficio de todas
estas cosas que acabo de mencionar en el
control de plagas la mejora de la
calidad del aire y que sean hermosos de
observar todo este beneficio hacia la
sociedad que viene de estos árboles se
contabiliza como un beneficio de 10
dólares por árbol un beneficio de 10
dólares por árbol lo que estamos
diciendo aquí es que más allá de los
beneficios que pueda obtener el dueño
del árbol existe un beneficio externo o
una externalidad para la sociedad así
pues estamos hablando de externalidades
positivas hay un beneficio externo de
plantar uno de estos árboles y este
beneficio está valorado en 10 dólares
por árbol como tomamos en cuenta este
beneficio dado este punto de equilibrio
estamos teniendo la cantidad óptima de
árboles en nuestra sociedad en los
últimos vídeos veíamos externalidades
negativas donde se tenía un costo
externo y agregamos ese costo a la curva
de costos en este caso estamos hablando
de beneficios externos
una externalidad positiva por lo que
vamos a agregar este beneficio en esa
curva de beneficios marginales
recordamos que esta curva es el
beneficio que obtienen las personas que
promueven estos árboles y esto le
agregamos el beneficio que está
obteniendo la sociedad y según este
estudio la sociedad está recibiendo 10
dólares de beneficio adicional así que
combinando estos beneficios nuestro
nuevo punto va a quedar aquí más o menos
son esencialmente tenemos que este
primer árbol va a tener casi 50 dólares
de beneficio pero si agregamos el
beneficio de la sociedad va a estar más
arriba llegará casi a los 60 dólares de
beneficio así que tomamos esta curva de
demanda y la trasladamos hacia arriba
por 10 dólares al momento de agregar los
beneficios de la sociedad y nuestra
nueva curva de demanda va a quedar más o
menos así podemos llamar a esta curva el
beneficio marginal más el beneficio
externo la curva de beneficio marginal
más el beneficio externo bueno vamos a
esta nueva curva veremos que tenemos un
nuevo punto de equilibrio diferente a la
anterior nuestro nuevo precio de
equilibrio va a estar más arriba más o
menos por acá en lugar de ser de 20
dólares ahora estará más o menos en 27
dólares y la nueva cantidad de
equilibrio a producir va a ser un poco
mayor a los 3 millones de árboles si
dejáramos que el mercado se comportará
de manera natural sin agregar esos
beneficios externos estaríamos dejando
fuera todo este superávit que podríamos
tener
si le damos los beneficios externos si
consideramos el punto de equilibrio
anterior del precio en el equilibrio y
la cantidad de equilibrio tendríamos que
se plantarían 2.7 millones de árboles
por año si señalaremos aquí el beneficio
extra que obtiene la sociedad en verde
el beneficio al consumidor es eso que
estoy señalando aquí en amarillo bueno
de hecho toda esta parte que soy
señalando en amarillo porque el punto de
equilibrio anterior está aquí y el
superávit de los productores aquí esto
en rosa pero estaríamos dejando fuera el
beneficio de la sociedad si tomamos en
cuenta el punto de vista de la sociedad
estaríamos dejando fuera está área
naranja de nuestros beneficios si es que
no creamos alguna forma de incentivar
que se planten más de estos árboles por
lo que en esa situación una manera de
llegar a la cantidad óptima de árboles
producidos para que la sociedad obtenga
ese superávit lo que se puede hacer en
el caso de las externalidades negativas
ponemos un impuesto ahora
con las externalidades positivas podemos
poner un tipo de subsidio podemos decir
oigan si ustedes plantan este árbol si
alguien planta este árbol planta un
árbol obtendrán un crédito de impuestos
de 10 dólares en esencia estamos
diciendo que quien plantea uno de estos
árboles tendrá 10 dólares menos en sus
impuestos en resumen estamos diciendo
que cualquier beneficio que se obtenga
del árbol les vamos a dar 10 dólares
adicionales de beneficio y con esto nos
estamos asegurando que se produzca la
cantidad óptima de árboles
ahora en esta circunstancia
esencialmente estamos dando todos los
beneficios externos esos 10 dólares de
beneficio por árbol lo estamos dando a
las personas que están plantando estos
árboles por lo que todo este beneficio
que estoy subrayando se vuelve beneficio
de ellos porque ellos son los que
obtienen los 10 dólares pero lo bueno es
que al menos ese superávit positivo está
yendo hacia alguien no se está perdiendo
no estamos renunciando a esta área
naranja